-Welcome back.
-Thank you, thank you.
It's great to be back.
-Well, let's talk about this.
Volume one of season 4 is
breaking all sorts of records.
-I know.
-I mean just smashing
the records.
It is number one on Netflix
in over 80 countries.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Yes.
-It's -- It's definitely
a crazy feeling.
I think I'm never really ready
for it until it comes.
And then, this fourth season
just came and --
and, oh, my God, it's like --
it's chaos, but I love it.
-This is the biggest show ever.
-I know.
And I love how they split it
into the two volumes,
'cause it keeps, like, the --
the hype going.
-Yeah.
-And it's -- it's great.
-But it also keeps you
from telling spoilers 'cause --
-Yeah, well --
I mean, I actually have
made some mistakes there.
[ Laughter ]
I -- because I --
You know what?
I literally
just realized this today.
I was going through
my Instagram, and I saw --
because I don't know --
am I allowed to, like, spoil
volume two?
-No.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Because I posted stuff
on my Instagram and --
of, like,
an explosion or something,
and it's from the second volume,
and people were like,
"Is this a spoiler?"
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I'm gonna get in trouble."
So, I literally
just took it down.
-You did it again?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But it's --
-I mean, they --
I know from --
The whole cast
has been on the show.
They call you the Tom Holland
of "Stranger Things" because --
[ Laughter ]
Because you spoil everything,
all the secrets.
-Yeah. No, it's not -- it's not
the greatest title to have.
[ Laughter ]
No offense to Tom Holland.
-Yeah.
-But, I mean -- you know,
I own it, and I -- the fans
love getting those spoilers.
[ Laughter ]
-No, they do not!
-They do.
They beg me for it.
-They don't, they don't.
Of course they beg you for --
-You guys love the spoilers,
right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
See?
-[ Laughs ]
-I'll keep them coming.
-You know, I --
I actually wanted
to ask you something.
Because this is season four,
and Will Byers
still has the same haircut.
[ Laughter ]
-It's rough.
-It's the greatest --
it's the greatest haircut in any
television show, I would say.
And this is season four
we're going into.
-This is -- I mean, I --
-No one else has this haircut
in the whole show.
-It's gone on too long.
[ Laughter ]
-But are the Duffer Brothers
just doing it to mess with you?
-Honestly, I think,
at this point, they are.
Because I've been begging them
since season 2
to get rid of the bowl cut.
And we're on season four now,
and they were like,
"Get ready for season 5
'cause it's not going away."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "What?!"
-Well, I thought it'd be
kind of fun
if we got some other --
-Oh, my God.
-I got some wigs
of different hairstyles...
-Oh, my God.
-...from the '80s.
-Okay.
-And I thought maybe we could
try them on...
-Let's try it.
-...just in case Will wants to
switch up the characters
and try a different hairdo.
This is -- This is perfect.
We love this.
But what if -- what if --
What if you got a perm?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my --
-Yeah. So can you try it?
Well, maybe I -- I'll put it on.
-All right, Duffers, if you're
watching this, this is Try 1.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait.
♪♪
-That's not bad.
I kind of dig that one.
-I --
-That one I kind of dig.
-It's --
-It's not bad.
-I think -- I think it's --
-It's pretty good, actually,
yeah.
-It's okay.
-Yeah.
-If I do a little...
-You can pull that off.
I think you can pull that off.
That's pretty --
Yeah, yeah, that's good.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I like that one.
All right.
-Okay.
-How about this? What if --
-I like it -- I --
-What if Will, in the '80s,
was a rock star?
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Oh, my God!
What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's -- yeah!
-Yeah!
Yes!
-I like this.
-Oh, I can see that.
-You got to try this one on.
-Oh, sure. Of course.
All right.
What if...
What if, um...
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, I love this.
-What if --
-I feel like Eddie.
-Yeah, this is kind of fun,
right?
-Yeah.
-People are tuning in right now.
What if --
What if Will has a -- had a --
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
-Yeah, that's actually --
I love this.
I can see this happening.
-Are we trying this one?
-How about a pompadour?
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yo, that's not bad.
Wow, that's cool!
That guy's cool!
-Hello!
Who's this?!
-Yeah, he's pretty cool.
Who's that guy?
He's kind of fun.
He's -- I dig him.
-Oh, my God.
-The last one --
I think this
is gonna be perfect.
-I need to take a picture to
send to the -- the Duffers here.
-Yeah, yeah.
Take a picture, yeah.
Yeah, I --
-Okay.
I'm sending this to them.
-You also got to send
the rock star one
because that's good, too.
This one, I thought,
is just evil.
If the Duffers are watching.
-Wait, I love this.
-He-Man --
He-Man was big in the '80s.
So I thought a He-Man wig
could be kind of rad, as well.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think this one.
I like this guy.
-This is awful.
-Why don't you do
the rock star one?
'Cause that one --
-Yeah.
-I like that one.
-Okay.
-Do we like the rock star wig?
The first --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Try that one on again.
That one's good.
No, I think rock star.
-Rock star?
-Yeah, do that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
Season five!
-Put that guy back on,
and I actually have a --
I have a wig of, actually,
your hair from the --
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So if you want
someone to play your older --
-That's exactly
what I look like.
-Yeah, like a secret brother
you never thought --
-You could be my --
my photo double.
-A photo double.
-Yeah.
-If you need a stunt double
or anything like that,
I'm your guy.
-All right, I'll let them know.
-Yeah.
I don't want any spoilers.
What can we say
about volume two?
-Okay, I forgot we're, like,
on a talk show here.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, you can expect
from volume 2, we got some --
some deaths coming, some --
some gore, and a big --
-Wow, that's a big spoiler.
-No, but --
-Dude, you just said something
that you can't say.
-No, but I didn't say who.
I'm just --
-I know, but that means --
What do you mean not?
You didn't say who?
There's not that many people
to choose from.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you guys can assume that
obviously somebody's gonna --
[ Laughter ]
-What?
No, we don't assume that!
-No?
-No!
We just think you're gonna
go to the mall and hang out
and, like, chill.
-Yeah. So, no, we're going to
the mall, and we're hanging out.
-So -- wow!
-Yeah.
-Wow.
Someone or some people?
-Well, I'm done here
because you're scaring me.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I don't want
to get you in trouble.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Noah Schnapp in volume 1
of "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers ]
-Why do you keep lying?
-What?
-Why do you keep lying to Mike?
-I'm not lying.
-You're not?
You're friends
with Angela and Stacey,
and you come to parties here?
-I have been to a party here.
-For Mom's work.
That's not what you implied.
I just --
I don't think Mike's gonna like
that you're lying to him,
and he doesn't deserve that.
And when he finds out,
he's gonna be mad.
-Okay. So, I asked for vomit
green, and I got vomit green.
Isn't that awesome?
-Noah Schnapp, everybody!
Noah!
-Thank you, thank you.
-And now we're doing
something fun after the break.
Stick around.
Come right back.
Don't leave. Come on back.